my name is Lindsey Graham and I'm a hair
stylist and salon owner in Salem Oregon
Lindsey Graham we're sitting in my chair
I would definitely cover those Gray's
there's a fine line between
distinguished and old of the man needs
products okay he's just coming over
slicking it and call it good make him a
little more modern maybe some shorter
spikes you're embarrassing me get above
1% buddy he need to put himself out
there more you need to get a first lady
see do I know any old gold diggers hmm
that would want to date Lindsey Graham
No
when it comes to dealing with me you got
a clenched fist on an open hand you pick
when it comes to me you might get like a
little hand on hand action like
sweetness and then if I don't like you
maybe we pull away and we're just like
finger finger we're not going to take
your second Amendment rights awake this
Lindsey Graham is very pro gun never
criminals I love me some guns no one
takes my guns we see eye to eye on the
gun issue I think we need to repeal it
and we need to replace it Obamacare
needs to go two points sort of like him
I might hatch tag twinsies